[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mom is somewhere else
hello good to be back got that break got
that break and I hope you're having a
wonderful time wherever you are and I'm
coming to you out here from Earth
pe rth in Western Australia and I'm out
here on the banks of the Indian Ocean
not far from the tasmanian sea and south
of the Timor and Banda Seas and I am I'm
happy to be here and I hope you're
having a good day I don't have a lot of
interim music or sweet dangles or
anything like that you know I don't have
a lot of those ear bells or fancy cat
whispers to kind of get us just easing
into the deal today but I'm happy to be
here with you and I'm grateful man I'm
just what's going on man I'm out here
did I we took last week off and I went
to a Bali I went to a country called
Bali for a little vacation to kind of
chill out and and just just not have to
do some stuff not have to do anything
you know these days we have we have so
many things that we have to do you know
email text text message listen to people
regular conversation look at something
close our eyes put on a hat brush our
teeth put on clothes eat something it
never ends you know buy someone a gift
it never ends
so to be able to have a little bit of
time where some of those things I could
just take off of the plate and just have
nothing on my plate and just be on a on
just a full life diet as far as
responsibilities go like a
responsibility diet it was nice and I
went I'll just tell you where you know
what I did I hope you you're doing good
you know hope things in your world or or
nice I hope you got a little bit of milk
in the fridge and I hope you got a
little bit of candy in your pocket a
sweet candy maybe a cinnamon barrel you
know at some point in time I don't
remember when it was really but they
started they made candy into special
shapes a little cannon you could get you
a little while liquor a little cannon
licorice used to come shaped like a
little like a little cannon or a gun get
a little licorice gun or you could get a
root beer barrel root beer came in a
little like a wooden shape like a wooden
barrel you know where they had a um they
had these little Canaries they had a
little kind of lemon canary candy I
remember when I was young and you get
your little look you know lohan full of
em lemon Canaries and just start a damn
aviary start a damn you know start a
damn you know like a little bird
sanctuary in your mouth but was I
talking about
oh I'll tell you this so so I took the
vacation and I went to Bali Indonesia
and looked to be honest man I'd never
heard of it
people said Bali you know I thought it
was somebody who mispronounced that
place aw Bally's Fitness Bally's 24-hour
fitness facility and you go into a
24-hour fitness joint that [ __ ] you know
it can be real some people
consider Fitness different things you go
in there 2 a.m. they got a dude in there
you know when he's using the treadmill
he's got it going really fast but he's
in there polishing rare rare gems and
stones on it like well laminates but to
him that's fitness you know he leaves
out of there in the morning with a
pocket of of sweet rubies and he's going
to trade that batch off for something
special you go to Anytime Fitness at
around maybe 10 a.m. or 10 p.m. you
might have a brother in there he'll take
a lady on a date there I've been at a
24-hour anytime snap you know Fitness
Bally's and they have you'll see you
know you have a dude in there a brother
take a lady on a date in there he'll be
in there he'll have a couple you know he
got two dates one guy saw this dude
named Jermaine he had to Lee he had one
lady over there on the treadmill and he
had another lady he was doing on the leg
press and he was going back and forth
and he's trying to you know this dude's
to time and I mean while this the whole
thing's a damn date he's got these
ladies out on a date and he's running
them back and forth got a little you
know got some wine in his squirt bottle
and he's winding him up and you know and
getting their calories off of him at the
same time and he's so you just never
know when you get into a fitness place
like that but what am I talking about
man I think I'm rusty I think I'm rusty
so today's episode is also brought to
you by Comedy Central has your new
favorite podcast and it's called
stand-up with Chris de Stefano every
week Christopher de Stefano who is a
friend of mine and who was on on here he
will he and his producer will be
listening to and discussing some of the
greatest stand-up of all time from
classic bits out of Comedy Central's
library to jokes from today's hottest
up-and-coming comedians they'll unpack
their favorite bits discuss the comedy
scene
call up other comedians and generally
get in everything comedy and hey since
the record at Comedy Central's
headquarters in New York City you never
know who might drop in imagine listening
to an expertly curated playlists with
jokes from John Mulaney and Hannibal
Buress or even better Maria Bamford and
Mitch Hedberg it's basically two
podcasts for the price of one completely
free and there's no podcast out there
that's anything like it subscribe and
listen to new episodes of stand-up with
Chris DeStefano every Thursday wherever
you listen to your podcasts
anyway I took this trip I went to Bali
oh yeah I went to Bali and and I was
nervous you know I've never traveled
anywhere by myself like I've traveled by
myself for work but I never traveled by
myself for just natural life you know
for like an experience and I went to
Europe when I was in college a
girlfriend and I went to Europe for two
weeks and then I've been other places
but only only with others never
solamente and that's Spanish for by
yourself
one-timer so I get you know I'm on my
way
Simon wreck some people know Dirt Nasty
the guy who really you know in LA was a
combination of you know him and Joe
Rogan's and you know a couple other guys
who really kind of Joey Diaz
Bobby Lee Chris D'Elia guys who really
helped me kind of catch some traction in
my own business in the past couple years
but Simon Rex was uh the guy who told me
you got to go to Bali man you got to go
to Bali and he's send the videos he's on
like a little go-kart and and it looks
exciting so I go
and I take Korean Airlines and look I'm
all excited I'm excited to get on the
plane I've been on the keto diet for a
month or six weeks and and let me let me
just before I tell you about the plane
let me tell you about the keto diet for
I forget here's some of my findings so
the no sugar right you got to stick to
the keto diet and I had there were a
couple times where I had some chocolate
that was only like 60% cacao or whatever
and you're supposed to be at like 75%
but but anyway here's what I found from
that diet is you lose a lot of weight I
found I lost a lot of weight by staying
off of anything processed and off of
sugar like I got lean like lean to where
I had I didn't know I could be as lean
like a lean in my muscle really like I
could see things that I've just memories
in my like I started remembering [ __ ]
like my brain got lean like it took the
gristle right off my brain and and
suddenly I remembered maybe a gift that
someone had got me a long time ago or I
remembered somebody who maybe had held a
door for me maybe you know 7 or 11 years
ago at a 7-eleven maybe even but it was
it was interesting because it just took
the it took a lot of the fog out of me I
noticed mentally so mentally from being
on the keto diet a lot of the fog was
lifted I felt more energy more free
energy because I'm always thinking oh I
got to have these carbohydrates and this
and that and I'm not saying go do the
diet I'm said look there's some
downsides of it I'll tell you in a
second but I just want to make sure that
I let you know the experience that I had
from a month on the keto diet and the
sugar you know I definitely noticed some
withdrawals man you want sugar boy what
is that a sugar
what is that do you get if somebody
whistles for a taxi bro you [ __ ] and
they've been having a doughnut or a
snack or a you know uh something
recently you said you even in the do you
hear somebody whistle and you [ __ ]
what is that
Oh sugar lips over there they had a
sucker two weeks ago at the bank you can
hear it on their lips
you know you get real caught into you
can you get jealous of it somebody you
see somebody leaving the store with a
bag of bread and you you follow them to
their car you don't even realize it you
followed them to their car and what am i
you kind of come out of a trance what
are you gonna do you're gonna change
you're gonna choke somebody out for a
loaf what are you gonna do you know so
you get really doing some withdrawals I
got angry I noticed I get real spicy a
real real real spicy with others I mean
somebody said something I don't like it
and not tell you no you know I just make
a face like mmm you know like somebody
just been stuffing mouth just been just
hiding a bunch of very very very young
lemons in my [ __ ] mouth mmm I make a
face like that mmm boy mmm so you got
you you know if you if you're one of the
Seven Dwarfs you grumpy that's how it
made me it made me you know I had some
withdrawals but it made me very alert
it made me when I woke up in the morning
I felt immediate energy and excitement I
don't have to wake up it was like I was
either asleep or I was awake and there
wasn't a lot of like shifting gears in
between the two I was ready to go you
know I felt like I started to feel like
a lot of foods and stuff really slow me
down really slow you down it's almost
like what you eat it's like if you have
a lot of bread then you you get bread it
up you know you might feel a you know
it's like you're a little slower in the
morning you got a couple of baguettes in
your step you know you got a couple of
you're on the basketball court you
slower you got a couple of croissants
stuck in your crossover you know you
know you start to feel like I start to
notice whatever I eat is wet that is it
impacts my behavior or it impacts my
emotion my fluidity or fluidity so I
started to notice that a hundred percent
you know you might have a couple you
know a little bit slower on the dance
floor if I've been having too much
dessert it kind of sticks to you I get
you know I have a couple of creme
brulees in my hip hop array you know oh
hey ho so I noticed that kind of stuff I
hate you know I maybe have a little bit
more you know I might have a couple wah
you know I might have some I just have a
little bit less I'm less fluid I'm kind
of slowed down and and so those are some
things that I noticed on the kiito's
diet some withdrawals from the sugar
much better energy much better mental
clarity very very clear anger more anger
now at the same time I was on chantix
non-cigarette pills and I mean people
you that the anger the anger could have
been from the pills you [ __ ] killed
you know you'll drive a car into a
[ __ ] shopping mall during a during a
Nike sale you know during a sale over
there at all Estee Lauder's so it's that
kind of vibe you know
so chantix is you know the non-cigarette
pills they'll make you do [ __ ] so I
shouldn't have been crossed I was cross
pollinating the different evacuations I
was trying to evacuate the sugar and the
bread and the key dude Iquitos diet and
I was also trying to evacuate nicotine
so I think I spoiled you know I spoiled
the
you know I spoiled myself as a testing
facility but but those are some things
that I did notice immediately my mental
clarity was was very clear but I was
very antsy and some of that could have
been just still withdrawals from the
sugar and I probably should have taken a
little bit more time but I think I'm
gonna die I'm going to do it again I'm
just gonna I'm going to make sure that
I'm not doing something else at the same
time like not mixing diets or not trying
to evacuate you know sugar and
cigarettes and you know alcohol or
whatever else all at the same time just
because that all that's a lot but those
are some things that I noticed I also
notice this less gas less body gas you
know less body gas man I if you got a
gas come out of you you y'all most
surprised you're like you know you
almost it's like you know it's like when
you hear so it's like it hearing a knock
at the door you're like oh [ __ ]
forgot I even had a door or if you hear
a doorbell these days you not not as
many people will come over anymore so
you know you hear a doorbell you're like
holy [ __ ] what is that oh I have a door
I forgot I have a doorbell I forgot
usually you get a text somebody says I'm
coming over but to hear that
old-fashioned do back in the day boy
when I was young and you heard that door
bell go off boy everybody tried to get
to the door to see who it was every kid
in the house man you could be doing
you could be crying you all you petite
you immediately you dry your tears up
you put on some powder whatever flour
sugar whatever you got to do to make it
look like you wasn't crying to tighten
up to get to the first to the door you
could be any other me could be in a coma
or pretending you're in a coma so you
don't have to go to school
oh [ __ ] that the doorbell goes off oh
[ __ ] all my levels are legit you yanked
that homemade IV out of your arm and run
to the door your mom's like I thought
she was dying boy when the doorbell went
off you might have a sister that wasn't
even born yet she's still in the womb
right not when the doorbell got ding
downed boy she you see a rappel from the
uh you know whatever that is that
lavender tightrope the UM the the you
Milledgeville you see her repelled from
that you Milledgeville cord she's off to
the damn door she know how to walk she's
just rolling over on her side when the
doorbell went off it was like the
Special Olympics boy cuz that [ __ ] was
special because people didn't ring it
that much and that [ __ ] was the Olympics
because everybody was trying to get
there to see who it was
oh is it somebody would yell in halfway
to the door like it's for me you don't
even know you just trying to lay claim
you get there dude you get there and you
open that door dude and it was somebody
it was somebody man it was Java's
witnesses boy and suddenly everybody was
like damn man it's the Lord and he's
going door to door different times dude
I missed that when the doorbell went off
he just something happened to you it
kicks a didn't matter what you were
doing Oh your whole world was left
behind when that doorbell went off
because that was opportunity there was
an opportunity there it was an
opportunity you didn't know what it was
and you were headed towards it I'm
talking about dude oh so let me just get
back into my trip but that was the Kido
so less body gas
[Music]
more clarity movement I would move a lot
faster quicker much clearer to
communicate anger though I found myself
getting angsty I didn't notice any drop
offs in my energy levels I noticed a lot
of lean lean body lean what else people
say you get keto crops or something or
keto crotch I didn't get it
my crotch seemed normal my crotch has
enough issues as is you know with that
mild - you know kind of lower case
erectile dysfunction Matt you know my
you know my dick it's not I'm never
right time my dick is lazy though I will
say that I got that LD and you know I'm
saying if you walked in it you know say
you walked in a work and a lot of dicks
are supposed to be at their desk you
know doing the typewriter my dick could
be over there about a wall you know
maybe having a cigarette or sir or lying
on one of his coworkers you know trying
to fly so those are some things that I
noticed I'm trying to think of anything
else so I get real clear on what my
experience was doing the key dose so
just you have just nothing anybody's I
asked him but I do get you know messages
saying hey what you know what's going on
so and oh I started to notice
immediately after about four days five
days I started to notice how some sugar
and some sugar candies were just too
much man like once I started to lose the
palate for like a snicker or even you
know you know uh whatchamacallit or uh
some Necco wafers once you started to
lose that palate man when you looked at
him again you were like oh that looks
nasty then you know me I love a baby
snicker
dude if I go to heaven you know and the
Lord lifts his skirt up I hope I hold
you know I hope about thirty baby
Snickers falls right out
his dress and and so when I you know
when I started to look at these candies
in it was just too much for me I just it
was you know it was surprising I was
like wow I now I see eight where that
sugar is and it makes me I don't want
anything that sugary it's too much it
felt fake and natural sugars I started
to really like the taste of like 80%
cacao chocolate the [ __ ] that you taste
you're like damn this ain't chocolate at
first but by the seventh day on keto
you're like dang that stuff is sweet you
start to really realize where sugar is
everywhere they'll put sugar on your
[ __ ] wife bra if they think you don't
like her and a lot of women use sugar
they know we you know you'll see a lady
show hot a couple of uh you know a
couple of Milk Duds or something on the
back of her neck she'll tape a [ __ ]
uh uh
tape you know a little short stack of
starbursts on the nape of her neck
because they know sugar attracts men
you'll see a lady back in a day she'll
put her head on the side and put a
couple drops of um of honey in her ear
that old-fashioned [ __ ] keep you
around sauce you know because they know
this sugar attracts so but that was my
experience man that was my experience
and even I noticed like a tomato for
we're really good it would taste really
sweet and that was about as sugar as I
got cuz you gotta stay off fruit as well
there was from a couple moments where I
cheated like it would be you know I
would have like a sunflower seeds and
like a banana or something at night a
couple times and that's just my
experience I hope to have a bigger and
more lengthly experience but that's been
my experience so far that I tried so I'm
on Korean Airlines and I'm in the sky
I'm on vacation I'm ready to you know
I'm
taking it easy now no more diets no more
this or that well I get up there they
bring and I look I got a first-class
seat
you know I treated myself this is my
vacation I'm sure you know I got a
little it was nice they had like a
little magazine there in Korean and
that's nice because you know what I
don't even have to read it if I see a
magazine in English I feel pressure I'm
like [ __ ] man I got to read that great
here goes a bunch of reading I have to
do but I see a magazine and Korean I'm
like bang bang
well can't read it a will so that
immediately was relaxing let's have a
bunch of [ __ ] I couldn't read if I
wanted to and then we get cruising and
they start bringing you food right and
look I have I've had food in some
different countries I like different
stuff but man I'll tell you different
people have different ideas of what food
is and Korean Airlines amazing airline
comfortable loving people very kinda at
one point in and the night it was like a
16-hour flight I've fallen asleep the
lady put my blanket back on my oh my oh
my on my shoulder but the food they had
on this Korean airline just left a lot
to be desired they they first of all
they bring you a bunch of little dishes
of things I don't even know what it is
something look like paint it looked like
I I thought they wanted me to do an art
you know but next thing I know I see
people around me spoon and all that a
different colors into their mouth the
one thing I recognized a dish of
jalapeno and that was like the nicest
that they had a bowl had fish in it and
chopsticks and I've had fish sticks okay
don't get me wrong I've had them but
I've never had them where you got to do
the math
yourself where you got to get in the
bowl and catch them I thought I was at
the carnival all I needed was a dude on
some [ __ ] middle-range
methamphetamines standing there next to
me you know well I'll miss approximately
throw him ping-pong balls to win the
damn dinner while I'm trying to eat it
this it was it was bizarre
especially when you when you are ready
to relax and somebody shows up to you
with something that is not relaxing man
they had something I've never seen it
before I didn't know if it was a
vegetable I don't know if it was if it
was mountain lion I didn't know if it
was a meat I don't know if it was an
idea I didn't know if it was granite I
had no idea what it was
could have been chocolate could have
been a dessert could have been an
epitaph could have been [ __ ] I don't
know could have been something could
have been siding could have been you
know something they were waiting to be
tested on a Forensic Files episode I
have no idea that's what all the trays I
had no idea what was going on they don't
know ma'am and in and some didn't they
bring you this I thought that was the
whole meal you know I had three or four
jalapenos did a little prayer and then I
pushed the thing aside then they bring
the plate back and put take all those
things away put more [ __ ] on them and
they do look on it at this point I don't
know what's going on I thought I was on
a really bad game show
I thought Howie Mandel was gonna pop out
from behind the seat I mean they had
cattails they had they had a little
stack I like look like damn aardvark
snouts or something with uh you know
what kind of a geriatric you know booyah
base peppermint remoulade on him it was
crazy man it was uh it was too much for
me man now also I'll tell you this
everybody on the plane was Asian
everyone because I was going to Bali
Indonesia but I was going through Korea
that was the flight I could get that was
mo
fair price so you know I saw them going
through Korea and everyone but me I'm
thinking you know I'll get on the plane
there'll be some other Americans will be
kind of excited or I'll see some in
Polynesian people no none of them know
that I get on and it's just all Korean
and beautiful people you know especially
the flight attendants man and just so
I'll take the the cleanest airplane I've
ever been on in my life Korean Airlines
you walk into the restroom as soon as
you leave one of the one of the flight
attendants walks in after you cleans up
the restaurant you need something they
pop up and they all look to have a very
and from my perception you can tell a
Korean person or this is how I've I
think they're they have very white look
to the skin some of them you know and
they almost put a makeup on some of them
look almost like you've ever been a
mortuary you ever had someone near that
died a couple people that died or
something and they you know they put
that uh they do a little bit of light
kind of plaster of Paris on them they
got that my you know a lot of these
Korean flight attendant ladies have that
deceased but fine like hot and deceased
you know like damn she's dead do you
know like kind of fine but it's just a
way it's their makeup style it's where
as we go for more like tan in the u.s.
they go for more of a pure kind of color
white and man it it looked I mean I felt
like I was in like that movie my girl
you know I was like Macaulay Culkin dude
it was beautiful I was hoping I'm gonna
let some bees loose on the flight and
you know maybe meet a lady they were
beautiful over there but they have that
mortuary style look you know very red
lipstick big beautiful eyes and kind of
flower kind of they put like a
like a light flower on like a white
color what else man so we yeah but
anyway then I get there and uh and Bali
was cool man it's very relaxing I stayed
in a place called Changu and I got me a
little I got there at midnight it's a
real quiet you know get to the hotel and
like there's literally some boys
standing there no shoe with uh no shoes
on and like a nightgown waiting for me
and I thought like damn I ended up in
some kind of a um you know I was nervous
to talk to him he worked for the hotel I
didn't want to end up in a damn you know
sexual ring or something
disorganized sex thing or something with
uh you know with some of these you know
people doing all that I would never do
anything like that so but he was just he
worked for the hotel and it was just
real peaceful and you go back there in
the back and had all these beautiful
trees and and they put me into this into
this hotel room and it was just relaxing
and I just got some rest
and I stayed there for a couple days
went down to the beach in the morning
went to yoga got in the water man it was
really cool but you had a lot of uh
construction going on a lot of
construction a lot of Western kind of
ideals coming you could see it and you
could see the people there like working
hard because there was a lot of money
coming in the Balinese and people but
you could also see how this place was
gonna change into a place that they
could never get back the place they once
had you know and so some of that was
kind of sad you know I was like wow this
is such an amazing place but it's it's
starting to get run over by business and
you know made me think a lot about well
when do we when do we stop doing things
because it's because business isn't
important you know
like at what point do we is it not about
the business you know what point is it
about the love of a place like at what
point do you say I'm not gonna build a
damn CVS right here because they got
because this is a beautiful place to
look at it just made me think you know
about some of that like man cuz it was
beautiful you know you see the faint the
father going by and he's got the two
kids on the back of the scooter and
they're just the kid you know one of the
kids is so young he can't even the wind
is making his eye it's too much for him
to keep his eyes open and his beautiful
dark-haired is blowin in the wind and
and that one look the other kid is maybe
two three years older and he's a little
more experienced so he can keep his eyes
open and they're all just holding on the
dad and yet it just made me think man
and in two years you know there'll be a
dang Subway sandwich right here by these
rice paddies we're right there they had
these beautiful rice fields and next
thing you know they'll have a Subway
sandwich over there and uh now is this
interesting it's like when is it okay
like how do you know I guess it's just
zoning and I guess it's their choice it
has nothing to do with me but just made
me think that about a lot of things how
a lot of things go by the wayside
because there's opportunity for business
and at what point do we start to make
laws or regulations or just choices as
humans to say man this isn't that
important is it that important to have
7g LTE phone so I can keep in touch with
my sibling or somebody or Janet or Larry
or is a veiled Rijn or anybody sure Lisa
anybody Quan Doris anyone how fast do I
need to keep in touch with
seen them in two years but how fast do I
need to have that upload how many more
trees got a good ounce we could get them
more Tower silky you know at what point
do we say it's not worth it it's worth
it sag you know to not have this much
technology it's worth it to re embrace
our set you know what we who we are as
humans and and maybe that's just crazy
thinking I mean look I'm I'm uh I mean
I'm on a computer right now
communicating over camera and video
camera but it just made me think that
man looking at that place and dude it
was cool you'd be out by the beach and
they had on one thing I noticed about
Bali they had dogs with nuts on them
running around just like when you were a
kid remember that remember how nice it
was you see a dog rolling by with them
big-ass [ __ ]
with them big with that hanging sack of
behold tits them nuts boy yeah bro I
remember that though you see and then
they have you know then some rich people
came moved in on accident to your
neighborhood they stay for one month and
their dog didn't even have any nuts and
you'd be like what where's your dog's
nuts at but Bali you got you at night
you see six or seven dogs running the
street maybe one of them have a little
deck of cards under his arm and one of
them got the cigarettes you know we're
doing it uh but Chewbacca the chewing
tobacco and they're gonna have some fun
and they got their nuts and everything
they're still living life that's Bali
baby
they got nature's loose here not America
where you got a bunch of bunch of
freaking eeks over there cutting animals
nuts off what's going on in America
we're cutting off of animals nuts when I
was young you had a everybody to have
male dog did
matter dogs out there doing sex with
everything you see a dog out there male
dogs doing it all meet me you know you
see three or four dogs doing at all
doing a little you know not um you know
doing that little a little bark bus you
know you see three dogs in a row humping
they called it humping you see three
dogs humping each other no women in it
maybe are two women who knows everybody
had nuts back then and it was just more
beautiful that's how you learn about it
too as a kid you see a couple dogs doing
sex you're like oh you know maybe I can
do that one day maybe I can be somebody
you know like muffin over there or like
uh you know like kibbles over there
maybe I can be somebody like one of them
it was just a different deal and it was
just you know and that's what I liked
about Bali you see a whole flock of dogs
going off to do something they had ideas
because you take the nuts off of some
the idea is kind of the idea is kind of
lose the wheels but not these Balinese
and bad little Barker's these little
wolf wolves
these boys was out there flexing and
even the ladies you saw some of the
ladies you know some maybe some ah some
Dalmatians a couple of Dalmatians kind
of rolled by and a spot and the dudes in
the distance and they flirtin these two
because they cuz the the energy still
out there
they still got nuts on the table and it
was it was just good to see man it was
really nice to see to remember what that
was like because when I grew up that's
how you learned about sex you see a
couple animals doing it and they were
having fun man and you whistle at him or
somebody you know toss a little stick at
him but it was different it was
everything was a different time man but
God
there was nothing more fun than when you
were young if you were bored in the
neighborhood at least a couple dogs come
over by and do sex for an hour something
gave you something to kind of not be a
part of but at least you felt like you
know like a like a member of society you
felt like a man and there's something
special and that that that that energy
is still alive over there in Bali and I
was over there in Changu and that's
something you can see in Bali is the
local dogs still getting at it being
hard Oh what else man what else was it
like there Oh Greg Oden was on my flight
so and he is a basketball player and he
played for Ohio State and so he was on
the flight and I was excited right when
I saw him I saw him years ago I did a
show at Michigan State University and he
was this is when he was playing
basketball and he went on to play for
some different teams he played for know
if it was the Pacers he played for
Memphis I think almost he had a he you
know he had kind of a hectic career
maybe Philadelphian he had kind of a
hectic under the Trail Blazers he had a
hectic career you know he just had some
physical limitations or you know I mean
he just he's a giant he's a giant
amongst men and so but I saw him on the
plane right when I got on I recognized
him him and his wife for going over on
vacation and that was pretty cool but he
had just had a nice energy about him and
I went up after him and I'm you know I
know Maurice Clarett came on the podcast
one time and they're both from the same
area I said hey you know I'm a friend of
maurices and and uh and I texted Maurice
I said Greg Oden is on my plane and he
said oh that's my man go tell him hey so
I was so nervous man because there's
something about meeting like a
basketball player somebody real tall I
think that makes regular heighted people
nervous
and so I was nervous but I went over and
said hello and and so that was it was
just kind of cool to meet like a giant
and like a legend like that oh what else
what else oh oh Bali another thing in
Bali you you can order they have an app
you can use in Changu and Changu they
have they have like it's real peaceful
and it's about 40 minutes from the
airport and the beach is right there and
there's nothing real commercial on the
beach
you go get enters in a lifeguard you
might die but they believe in
reincarnation there so you die you know
you're back an hour later I mean you're
a toddler and you're a [ __ ] you know
you might be a lizard or a lizard or
whatever down the street but you're
alive you know you but that's kind of
neat that they have that there but it
was good I would recommend it and then
we went and saw the rice paddies one day
re my feature came and surprised me
because I left my retainer in America
and he brought it over and so that was
cool and then I went to an AAA meeting
one day there and what else oh they had
a friend a couple friends of Simon Rex's
kind of took me around so anyway a lot
of name-dropping in this one and then
and then I don't want to forget to tell
you guys whatever else happened but I'm
getting kind of tired of talking about
myself mm-hmm what else you can get a
good deal there you can get a good villa
you know a couple hundred dollars a
night which I know is expensive but if
you're really splurging on yourself and
and taking a vacation you can get a
villa where you have your own little
place and your own pool your own little
pool in your little yard and that dude I
didn't there was two days I don't think
I saw anybody
the guy from the front brings your
breakfast is dude day Wow
he brought in the meals you know he had
beautiful eyes young guy when she was a
woman but he wasn't you know wouldn't
mind seeing a little bit of tits you
know and anything else about that place
oh one thing I noticed let me see this
in Bali the religion in Bali a lot of
Buddhists Hinduism and they believe once
you die you come back so they live with
a different set of values like to them
everything isn't so severe
because if [ __ ] you get hit by a truck
lucky you now you get to be a
four-month-old again you're gonna have
at it in your mouth in an hour you know
you in your thirties you get but you
know somebody you get hit by a [ __ ]
arrow in the neck lucky you forty
minutes later you and newborn over there
in Kuala Lumpur and you got a tit in
your mouth and you back in the ballgame
so it's kind of the so you live with a
whole different mindset you don't live
with this mindset that like everything's
on the line right now
you live with a mindset like oh I'm just
once again I'm passing through existence
I've been alive for who knows how long
and once again I'm passing through
existence and this time I'm a plant or
this time I'm a young woman or this time
I'm a king or this time I'm a warrior or
this time I'm a baby that doesn't even
make it through birth but you build up
these experiences inside of you and
those are the and those become the the
colors of your soul kind of those become
the the patterns and the textiles and
the and those become the
the the pine needles in the and and the
stray piece of of yarn that make up the
bird's nest of whoever you are these
imprints through time you know through
different existences and this
interesting man is and it was so then
when you notice that when you're
interacting with a lot of the Balinese
and people you notice that I mean why is
this person so calm because there's
nothing on the line man and that piece
was just it was beautiful I mean it
really was beautiful to see their joy
when there's nothing it doesn't matter
man when it's just they know that you
know that they're that that it's not
it's not life or death it was
interesting and they look and I could be
you know I'm not denouncing any other
religion but it was nice to just see
that that level of faith and what that
feels like and for that connection to
see you know I am a proponent of faith I
am and and so it was just nice to seem
as beautiful to see real beautiful to be
in that in that environment and see
people to be at peace and it made me
think more about the peace that I want
to have you know because you know I have
been a little stressed out this year I
mean a lot it a lot actually and
sometimes I want to have more peace in
my life but a lot of that is just me
turning it over to a faith or to a
higher power and letting it out of my
own you know just quit trying to control
everything I mean sometimes I just get a
little sick of myself you know what else
I haven't even gotten Australia yet
I want they have one other thing that
was real cool in Bali that I noticed was
you can go get coffee Luwak they got a
place called Luwak coffee where they
have mongooses and a mongoose is like a
ferret that you know it's like a ferret
like say if you mix like Andrew Dice
Clay and a ferret
that's a mongoose you know I have real
edgy you know they're real they might do
be doing a [ __ ] Winston or you know
you know just attacking a lady or doing
whatever you know they're wild so so
anyway they had Mongoose and they eat
these coffee beans and they do they do
them out their body out the back door
duty and once they got them out the
people take the beans because the beans
the Mongoose doesn't digest the bean and
so the beam comes out their body they
take the bean wash it off wash off the
rest of the muck you know the mung where
the [ __ ] you know the where the the
mongoose mung dews the monk do do they
wash it off and they take that bean and
then they make coffee out of it you buy
it
so you got that special duty hitter bra
you know so but that's a real thing it's
called Luwak that Luwak coffee and you
can look it up and that's beans have
been straight out that mongoose gut see
you got that : hitter
so sometimes coffee makes you feel like
you have to go to the bathroom well this
coffee already went to the bathroom so
you're safe I guess um I don't even got
in Australia yet I wonder if I should
just wait until I get back to tell you
about what Australia was like I'll tell
you right now I'm in Perth and I'm in
Western Australia and it kind of reminds
me of Denver and it's beautiful and the
tour has been wild man we've been
standing some nice places and
[Music]
it's crazy you stayed a nice hotel you
know it's three four hundred dollars you
know a night like I do it at this price
I'm not even going to sleep you know
I'll lay down for a half hour that's $40
worth of freaking money so you feel like
you got to stay awake and just enjoy the
whole room
you know I drink probably gallon and a
half of water out of the faucet earlier
trying to decide you know if it tasted
better than if you in like uh
you know I'm usually stay at the Best
Western er to Hampton Inn in Hampton Inn
they got good water right out the tap
bro but this and I the [ __ ] here is a
little better I did notice that um but
yeah I do and this room you do all kind
of stuff you look at the plants they got
a plant
they got another plant right over there
are two plans what it's almost like a
damn farm it's like a little say you
stay awake cuz you don't want to miss a
thing do I still miss you baby so yeah
being in a nice hotel room it's
definitely a different vibe but I don't
want to get too used to it you know I
don't want to get too used to it
but yeah it's been good we went to
Sydney the first night it was like 2,000
people at a theater and dude it blew my
balls open I mean it blew my balls open
like a damn Polynesian Beach dog so this
was crazy and then went to Melbourne and
just cool fans man not fans but just
cool supporters of this past weekend
that came out of the pot like I don't
know him and it just blows my mind it's
hard to really connect the dots like how
you know we talk about stuff on here and
then it just we live it out in the world
you know that a young guy who had been
on the podcast episode I think 139 or
something and he called it about losing
weight and he lost 30 pounds since then
this kid named Jamie it's good to see
him in person I remember talking
him on the phone just so crazy and then
here he was alive and we were in each
other's lives they had a guy that came
out in Melbourne and I'll say this the
Melbourne shows were in a they put him
in like us almost like a student it
looked like a place where you would do a
school you know like uh they didn't have
any theaters available so they put it at
like a convention centre and it was the
the audience was awesome the people that
came were awesome the people that I met
amazing kind but the the venue I thought
it was nice but it was just kind of a
[ __ ] place to see comedy comedy is
something that needs to be in an
environment that were the walls and can
appreciate it and these place was kind
of a thing something you'd do anything
you could do whatever in there and just
seemed like general a general space that
didn't have any like the walls had no
desire or care of their own like the
walls just look like they didn't even
know who their parents were you know or
like they had parents they just seemed
kind of like somebody had built a box
for us to to do anything in we could
have done a murder in there we could
have made soup we could have done
anything you know we could have we could
have done anything just stood in the
corner and lied to each other could have
been whatever but but then we came where
else did we go to Sydney Melbourne Perth
that's where we are now and we have one
show here last night and it was fire and
we had two other shows in Sydney we went
back and forth and and the shows have
all been cool man it's been really
caught us was the venue in Melbourne had
been different but in the future maybe
we'll hope for a different venue I'm not
complaining at it it just wasn't ideal
for comedy and yeah and they had a guy
who came out who would just say you know
he said he said hey man I lost my mother
and my sister in the past year and you
know your podcast has really been
awesome there's just moments everywhere
it's cool and it makes me feel okay and
that really made that really was that
was really cool and I think he's
supposed to send me a message online but
I didn't get it so if you hear that
brother we send that again just so I can
um something keep my eyes open for you
for it I'd love to catch up oh but yeah
just cool man you know just uh I wish
you had more time to meet everyone it
just you know it's a lot of travel and
it's a lot of quick movement it's a new
country and people are so polite here it
almost feels like I'm on a prank show a
lot of times people are so kind and
Chris Lilley came out do what if you
have not seen Summer Heights High it's
absolutely wonderful somebody last night
brought me his other movie called we can
be heroes I've never seen it but imagine
getting to meet like George Washington
or something just somebody who just was
like an X somebody who you just they
blow your mind
when you watch him do creativity and
that was him for me man he's like it's
like it's like meeting a shark outside
of the water or it's like seeing a sea
horse at an arcade he just there's
something so rare about that guy Chris
Lilley and he has a new show lunatics
and I urge you to start with his old
stuff and migrate forward with it she
can get the full vastness of who that
man is one of a kind man one of a kind
but anyway sorry to be talking about
myself so much you know one thing it's
interesting that you know there's
there's cost with every opportunity like
this is it's been awesome obviously
being over here we solve another week of
shows to do but it's been I kind of
missed sometimes as being at the Comedy
Store you know like a year ago I was at
the Comedy Store four nights a week and
I've just got to be there every week and
you know just see all my buddies and see
like the other comedians and and you
start to feel a little bit like not left
out but
you know life just goes on man life cuz
life goes on
you know that's why it is such a it's
not critical but it is it's such a
unique opportunity it's a unique
opportunity we have here and maybe we
get it again but even if we get it again
it's just such a unique opportunity when
you look at all the rest of the energy
out in the world and the outer space and
the ground and plants and anson and you
see that we get to be at this forefront
of this ability to be able to connect
with one another and and hug someone or
let somebody know we care about them or
or miss somebody even missing some
something or missing somebody is what a
unique thing that is you know like I
miss my friends at the Comedy Store I
miss just being there and just hearing
some of them laugh or something I mean
it sounds gay ass but you know we're
just seeing them in the hallway or you
know getting to give you know they have
the Eleanor Eleanor Kerrigan as a
comedian always give her a hug every
time she always is very sweet and you
know Steve Simone is always up there and
I see him all the time and it just are
just different people's faces my buddy
Adam egit who works over there and he's
really troubled just like me and we you
know it's just it's interesting missing
people is interesting you know not to
mention Coco Diaz you know and just
getting to see Rogan and de lis and just
even see what they're you know talking
to them is like trying to talk to a
comet or talk to a shooting star you
know they're just there's so much going
on in their lives but it's it's good but
even just have that moment with them
just to touch base and shake hands or
give a hug or see Bobby Lee
you know it's funny I didn't realize how
much the Comedy Store is kind of like my
home sometimes today's episode is
brought to you by Ridge wallet Ridge
wallet is a it's a wallet and you and
you may not have one and it's a you know
a lot of times that a wallet will be
something you you hear about Oh her you
know you hear about that wallet and
it'll be but but when you think about it
it's in the back of someone's pants you
know what's something else to keep in
the back of your pants
you know duty may be gum if you sat in
gum so why would you keep your wallet
back there well Ridge has that new front
pocket carry and Ridge wallet is a haul
it's a it's like a holster it's like a
holster for your money and your goods
and you can go to Ridge wallet comm
slash hitter and you will get 10% off
that order and you want that front
pocket carry you want to be able to keep
all your your ID your credit Carter II
all of that keep it in that front pocket
nobody's stealing something out of your
front who is maybe your wife maybe and
they're gonna get it anyway so you might
as well give them that easy access and
at least put access to your money right
up near you do you feel me and that's
old-fashioned math right there Ridge
wallet comm slash hitter for 10% off but
yeah just such a neat opportunity and
I'm just grateful I'm grateful for this
opportunity you know to think man I came
to another country and got to meet like
one of my favorite creation creators
Chris Lilley and I don't think the guy
knows how much how amazing I think he is
and how rare in the world he is I think
if you don't know you go get in him find
Summer Heights High find Jonah from
Tonga angry boys go find one of these
things and get into this strange man's
universe and then come to Australia and
you're gonna have such a unique
experience I went to an Australian rules
football game yester
you know this I'll finish with this
little deal and thank you to everybody
in Australia that's come out and all
people that are bought tickets to all
the other shows in the u.s. I think the
only shows that we're still trying to
sell tickets for and are in Norway which
I don't know if I can know where that is
man as sad as that is Norway and uh
Stockholm Sweden
but this um I was gonna say oh so this
happened so we flew in to Perth and it
was like maybe a four or five hour
flight him man we'd had it before I got
home maybe like one the morning before
got to bed by about 2:30 you know how to
be downstairs at 7:00 so no not too
crazy but kind of a busy morning get to
the airport we get to wherever we get to
Perth which I mean it's on the other
side of Australia and um we get here and
they have we get oh they lost one of my
bags so and that's fine that happens
which was so funny because there was
like 40 open seats on the plane so I so
just makes you wonder how it all works
out but that's what happened and then so
we get there we have to deal with the
lost bag and we get into a rental car
and there's an alarm on the car that
like one of those things when the doors
open
it just blinks like a mix-up but all the
doors were closed so we just had that
going on the whole time we're driving it
and you know I had a 1984 Ford Escort
for a while and there was a it got stuck
on a Christian Christian music station
and you couldn't turn it off so every
time I drove that car it had Christian
music going and I had that car for about
four years so and talking about trying
to get I mean especially in high school
we trying to get a little bit of uh of
La ID you hear me in case there's any
children
watching this but I'm talking about
full-on sexual the last thing you want
on the radio Christian music because
that's the opposite of sexual boy so
that stuff was hard you know not as hard
as I was dark i but it was hard but
anyway the remember how to be a podcast
be a podcast guy the anyway and we get
there that takes forever the bag then
the the beeping thing i get to the hotel
about lost my mind i was just stressed
tired wanting to take a nap
i go walk to the coffee shop and there's
a sport here called australian rules
football and i've been messaging with
one of the players for a couple months
this guy Mitch that place for the
Brisbane Lions and so he said he'd
invited me to come to a game and I
didn't know if I could make it or not
and I was just all tired I was like I
don't know if I I couldn't even find his
uh his uh I couldn't find his Instagram
message and our messages and then I
walked to a coffee shop down the street
and he's in the coffee shop and so and
then he it was great because you sister
such a neat guy and he invited me to the
game got me a ticket so next thing you
know three hours later I go get a nap I
go to the to the game and I'm sitting up
in the stands by myself watching
Australian rules football dude the
stadium was beautiful looked like I was
on the moon I felt like I was on the
moon it's like a perfectly kind of round
state it was just it was amazing they
lost by one point but it was a great
game but here it was like oh this whole
morning I'd been all frustrated man the
bag is lost now we got to wait for the
baggage thing at the airport and this
[ __ ] beeping for a twenty minute car
ride this [ __ ] won't do nothing and it
reminded me of christian the christian
music gonna make me want to [ __ ] a
little and so then i'm tired and i wanna
[ __ ] but the music's going on and i'm by
myself except for ari in the and and the
guy who's driving us over there and
I'm just like man I could have been
taking a nap I'm so tired I I'm just at
my wit's end but if all that hadn't
happened that it slowed us down cuz we
stopped the car three or four times to
try and fix the alarm then I don't then
I'm not at the coffee shop at the right
time I don't run into the to the
Brisbane Lions their Australian League
football team Australian rules and I
don't end up at the at the game so it
just made me just kind of just like this
like was a moment that was like man as
much as I want to try and control things
the path that I'm on
you know there's great opportunities if
I can just relax and just be on this
path path Perth Perth it's kind of like
path a little bit but anyhow I've been
rambling a little bit I don't I don't
even know how to do this anymore
just so crazy we're gonna be in a new
studio whenever we get back home but in
the meantime I'm gonna get back out here
now in Australia I'm gonna go take a
walk and I'll just enjoy this
environment that I'm in and just what a
blessing and this has just been awesome
and just to get to be out here in the
world and uh and just so many nice
people that just come up and care and
and I just want to say thanks you know
thank you so much man I care too you
know and I care about so many that so
many people that come out and and I wish
I could just find more ways to express
that sometimes and in the future I think
that that uh that I will but but I'm
gonna do the best I can to take
advantage of this path that we're on so
you guys be good to yourselves we don't
have any intro and outro music I don't
have any everything's not hooked up but
I'm grateful to already Manas my the
other comedian working with me
this that's here and and I'm sure
there's a lot of stuff that I'm
forgetting I'll try to think of more of
it later but but this is the first
episode ever of this past weekend live
from Australia or unlife I don't know
what it's called if it's not live but
it's you know almost live almost live
from Australia man this Perth out here
you guys be good to yourselves I mean
you guys deserve it and uh and thank you
a lot of cool stuff we got
I think Biloxi Mississippi that just
sold out over the weekend happy Memorial
Day to all the men and women of service
in every country in Australia in Korea
in the u.s. you know I do notice that
Australian people have a lot of
Australian pride and it's cool to see
and that's something that I know that I
hope we don't lose in America you know
we shouldn't lose pride and being and
being American I feel like a lot of
times that you know there's forces out
there that want to take that away from
us or sell our pride off or trick us in
and believe in that feeling like being
able to be in America or live in our
whatever our country is if your
countries Australia or America or Korea
or Guam or Vietnam or Viet Guam that you
should be able to be proud of that
you should be able to be proud of that
and it's cool to see you get over here -
and you wonder like a lot of people over
here they recognize that the media is
really tricky and you know you start to
realize that okay there's a lot of
people are questioning what's going on
in the world these days in this
electronic world and that's what's neat
about to get over here and get some
human connection with one another
because you see okay okay you guys see
this is happening to you guys - on this
happen in US this is yeah oh yeah the
media that the news wants us at war if
we end up at war they get to cover it
they're in business forever they're in
business till the end sorry I'm I'm
rambling and I'm getting probably a
little bit political maybe
not but anyway you guys be good to
yourselves man and thank you so much for
all for this opportunity
what a ride dude what a ride what a
friggin ride dude whatever I love you
I'm just wondering how could I be so far
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
now I'm just on the breeze and I feel
like these leaves I must be
[Music]
little town for me to slap that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
sound of strong
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with a heavy level in these wills that
are been robbed
no they won't
[Music]
to make him some word I came away
I'll tell you
[Music]
[Applause]